denise as cases rise clark county is
renewing its focus on getting everyone
vaccinated that can be commissioners are
getting creative as they try to reach
as many people as possible kate houston
breaks down some potential
opportunities for clinics i go to unlv
so i do plan
to go back in campus and just making
sure i'm safe along with everybody else
angelica martinez received her covid19
vaccine monday
being around family i mean we're a small
family they all work in the service
industry as
i do as well so i feel like just making
sure that we're following
whatever they recommend to keep
everybody else safe this is good news to
clark county chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick and that motion carry
who says they're working hard to reach
young people like martinez this new
variant
is very hard especially on the younger
generation
in addition to 18 to 40 year olds
kirkpatrick says they're trying to find
ideal clinic hours for those who work
around the clock
clinics could be hosted at job sites car
washes and more malls
we did see a line for the first time at
the galleria
this past weekend so we're encouraged by
that
kirkpatrick says it's important to
increase vaccination rates over the next
few weeks ahead of the new school year
and flu season the delta variant and the
common cold have similar symptoms
and kirkpatrick doesn't want further
spread we're all working to ensure that
schools
open and that we do not have to close
but
we have a small gap and i'm pretty
confident that
the community that i live in will come
together and do their part
kate houston 8 news now as students
prepare to head back to class the health
district offering
mandatory vaccines in the covid 19
vaccine at schools across the valley
for a complete list head to our website
8newsnow.com